اطفال
مجالات في التعاون داخل الولايات المتحده
بحيث نعمل على تنسيق قطاعات الدفاعي
والفضاء والمجالات العلميه من اجل مراقبه
المناخ
وقد اجرينا مناقشه مفصله حول تخفيض التضخم
وسوف ناخده في صربي هذا الموضوع قال
الولايات المتحده
والاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يجريان استثمارات
كبيره في مجال الطاقه
العالميه في مجال سوف نعمل على تعزيزي
الابتكاري والاختراع في اثناء على ضفتيه
الاطلسي مع الولايات المتحده وكذلك من
خلال مشاوره مستمره رغم وجود بعض
الاختلافات بيننا حول هذه المساله
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا سوف يعملن على
تعزيز الصحه على المستوى العالمي
وتصادف زياره الرئيس المكرون في اليوم
العالمي للايدز هنا ان نعمل على تعزيز
الجهود من اجل انهاء مرض العز في العام
2030 وتحقيق كافه الاهداف المنشده ومن اجل
فعل ذلك لابد لنا من الاستثمار كافه
الادوات الموجوده بين ايدينا ل- همم هذا
المرض ولهذا فاننا همم نشعر بالفخر اللي
همم ناخذ
المبادره من اجل العمل على راقد
ما قدمته فرنسا من رياده عالميه وكنا قد
قد قدمنا في صندوق العالمي لهذا الغرض
اكثر من 60 مليون دولار الامر الذي سوف
ينقذ حياه الناس في سوره العمل لو لي ان
ادرج كافه المجالات التعاون فيما بيننا
التي تحقق وتقدم فسوف ان نتحدث لفتره
طويله دعوني اختك مكالمه كلمتي بالحديث عن
الاستثمارات المشتركه التي سوف تعود
بالنفع على شعبان ونحن نحتفي بالذكرى
السنويه السابعه
الثانيه والسبعين في مجال التعاون العلمي
همم الامر الذي كان جوهريا وتجلى في العقد
الماضي بصوره محدده سوف تبقى تحالفتنا
قويه حتى الاجيال المقبله
اشكركم مجددا على كل ما تقوم به دولنا معا
في مجال التعاون وان اداره
وسياستنا الخارجيه تتماشى مع ما تقدمه
فرنسا وهذا التزام كبير من جانب لذا لانني
سعيدهم بلقائك صديقي واتطلعه للعمل معك
وهذا اقل ما يمكن قوله
وانا كافه من هو هنا يرحب بك بحراره
شكرا السيد الرئيس
شكرا على هذه الكلمات اللطيفه التي تعكس
طبيعه النقاشات التي اجريناها لكن الاكثر
اهميه ان الاستقبال الذي
قضينا به يعكس
مدى الحراره
وعمق الصدقه التي تجمعنا
الوفد الذي رافقني في هذه الزياره
وفيما يخص الموضوع الطاقه
افتح ما الذي نقوم به سويه في اوكرانيا
فنحن سوريه من ندين هذه الحرب
التي شنتها روسيا فضلا عن جرائم الحرب
الذي التي تم اختراقها على اراضي اخرىنيه
واننا نقوم بدعم الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يعمل
عن الدفاع عن المواطنين الاوكرانيين
ونود ان نشكر الولايات المتحده على كل هذا
الدعم الذي قدمته لان هذه الحرب تؤثر
بالموت تعمل
اوروبي بصوره مباشره وقد قررتم ان
تستثمروا وان تسهموا في هذه الجهود
المشتركه وفي هذا السياق ان مناقشه تناهى
هذا صباح كانت تطرقت الى مبادره سوف يتم
كشف النقاب عنها في الاسابيع القليله
المقبله للاستمرار في تعزيز دعمنا
للقوات الاخرانيه
ومساعدتهم على الحاق الهزيمه في روسيا
وسوف نقدم الدعم للشعب الاوكراني للصمود
بالانجليزي
من البناء المدنيه التحتيه
الامر الذي جعل الشعب الاوكراني بحاله من
الياسرون بمخاوف كبيره من من فصل الشتاء
المقبل
واوده في هذا السياق ان اشكركم على
التحضيري على تحضير لمؤتمر سوف يتم عقده
من اجل هذه